germany today takes over the rotating
presidency of the european union
here in berlin chancellor angela merkel
is about to discuss her plans
for the six-month term with lawmakers in
the federal parliament the bundestag
berlin will guide the course of the
block at a time of huge social and
economic upheaval
triggered by the global coronavirus
pandemic
germany kicked off its eu custodianship
by projecting the words
together for europe's recovery onto
berlin's iconic brandenburg gate
the slogan is a reference to the damage
caused by the virus pandemic
which has plunged european economies
into recession
chancellor angela merkel has described
it as the greatest
challenge the eu has ever faced
we're waiting on angela merkel to begin
her address to the german parliament but
in the meantime i'm joined by dw
political correspondent nina hasa
at parliament nina the motto for the eu
presidency
is together for europe's recovery what
is angela merkel's plan
the german government will throw all its
weight behind efforts to get the
european union out of this
very existential corona crisis of course
the german government had completely
different plans for its eu presidency
that always takes a half a year
but then came corona and now the
chancellor has understood that she does
need to take drastic measures
and to get the approval of all the other
member states in the european union
to push through a plan a rescue fund
that is worth
750 billion euros to help the countries
that have been hardest hit by the corona
crisis and get it out and of course that
is going to be an extremely difficult
process
but today here at bundestag she's going
to try and convince
german members of the parliament that
this is vital because also it
makes german the german economy depends
very much on the european market germany
is an export nation
some 70 percent of trade is done with
its european partners
so it's very much in germany's interests
to get the european
economy going again you know we have to
talk about the 750 billion euro
uh rescue plan from the from the eu 500
billion dollars
sorry euros of which coming from france
and
germany but are there any other
priorities that germany will have during
these six months
of course there are a lot of crises and
challenges that are not going to go away
just because we have a virus pandemic
across the world and there is of course
the climate crisis we have to remind
ourselves that
the eu wants to be climate neutral by
2050
and there is a lot on the table there
that needs to
be done for that to happen then the the
european union still doesn't have a
functioning migration and asylum system
and with a
crises around the world of course that
issue is not going to go away there will
be refugees
coming into europe and the eu needs to
agree on ways how to deal with them
and then angela merkel wanted to host an
eu china summit in september she
did postpone that citing corona reasons
but the issue of china is of course
high on the agenda also in international
news also today so the eu
desperately needs to find a common
strategy
regarding china that those are some of
the core issues and last but not least
we also have the deadline for the brexit
transition
looming in december and if the eu and
the united kingdom can't agree on a deal
on their future relations
that might mean that the united kingdom
will crash out of the european union
at the end of the year so a lot on the
table for the german government
but a lot of this also requires
consensus and that is principally what's
going to be
principally what's going to be required
i think i'm going to
head take our viewers straight to the
german parliament nina because
chancellor angela merkel has begun her
address to members of parliament
of the bundestag in my introductory
words here since it is the
first of july and the eu presidency
is now assumed by germany in a difficult
time
germany has assumed the presidency of
the council of the european union
and naturally our presidency will be
overshadowed
overshad
overshadowed by the corona pandemic
our efforts to contain it
return to a new normal if you like two
weeks ago
i asked for your support for the
unprecedented recovery plan
that we have in order to achieve the
economic and social recovery in europe
the european council two weeks
ago just looked at this and we agreed
that we find ourselves in an
situation and we need to have unusual
solutions so that
europe can emerge from this
unprecedented crisis
our positions are very different the
president of the european council
jean-michel
has got a and has invited everyone on
the 17th
of july to discuss this issue and
there'll be many talks that will be
necessary and i for example
we'll also be involved in these and i
will be working closely together
with him and with others so i would like
to achieve
a union as quickly as possible so that
the economic recovery
can take place as quickly as possible
and sustainably as well what's important
to me is that
the economic recovery benefits everyone
and that it's not just about
companies and employees but that we also
retain and strengthen social cohesion in
europe and that means that the
opportunities for young people in europe
must be
preserved and this is why in our
presidency we will be pushing
for a youth guarantee the possibility
for every young person to get a job
but in the six months ahead we won't be
only dealing with combating the crisis
but we'll also be working intensely
on how we can address climate protection
digital sovereignty and europe's role in
the world
in the future two weeks ago
i discussed this in some detail and
today i'd just like to refer to a
further challenge facing us in
our presidency of the eu that is the
question of the future relationship
between the european union
and the united kingdom progress
made here to be
cautious about it have been modest what
we have agreed
with the uk is that we will accelerate
progress here so that in autumn we can
have some kind of a
an agreement that would be then ratified
later i would push for a good solution
but we must and should
in the eu and in germany prepare
ourselves for there being no deal
the expectations of germany's
eu presidency are high and i can say on
behalf of the german government that we
are determined to do everything in our
power
so that as europeans we can make
progress together
for europe within europe and with our
international partners
and i'd like to ask all of you in your
contacts to the parliaments in the
member states
to support us in our targets
within the german presidency because
only if we get the support from the
national parliaments in all of the eu
member states will be able to tackle the
major challenges facing us so the motto
of our presidency is one that we need to
fulfill with life together
making europe strong again thank you
this brings us to question time and the
first
what do you say with that this is an
attack on
the rule of law in the state you didn't
want to have the
minister of the interior scrutinize this
you didn't want
responsibility here you just wanted the
left-wing press to be able to
commit libel left right and center are
you clear of the fact
that you are preventing the minister
for whom you created an internet
act
to incite hatred against the police in
the left-wing
tax newspaper
referring here to a satirical article so
what is it
that makes you muzzle
our minister of the interior
and allow them to attack the police and
19 were injured in the riots in
stuttgart
the german minister of the interior has
of course the full support of the
chancellor and the german government
for supporting the law enforcement
agency and that police officers need our
support
and that this is a matter of great
concern
the german parliament laying out
germany's priorities over the next six
months as
germany takes over the rotating
presidency of the european
union making a number of points
respectively the main priority there for
the german government
is the coronavirus recovery plan for
the eu we can go straight to our
correspondence
in berlin we have nina hasa and barbara
basil
in brussels nina i'd like to come to you
first
it was really a long expected lines
wasn't it this speech the coronavirus
recovery plan
front and center
yes and i found it striking that uh
angela merkel the german chancellor
called on the german bundestag on the
parliament to give her
its full support for all the measures
that she feels she has to take
in the coming months that are vital
to get the eu out of this corona crisis
she says
we have to find progress for europe we
have to move the european union forward
and we can only do that if all the
national parliaments agree of course
and when you look at the rescue fund of
course that is
a very controversial issue there are a
couple of member states
in the european union that are extremely
reluctant
when it comes to that proposal that was
put forward by german chancellor angela
merkel and the french president so a lot
of convincing needs to happen
in the capitals across europe let's go
across to brussels where barbara basil
is standing by
for us barbara germany really does have
its work cut out for itself doesn't it
trying to convince the other members to
get on board
with this coronavirus recovery plan
it's a hugely difficult task really
because what angela merkel will have to
do
is balance interests the interests of
the northern and the so-called frugal
states
the netherlands austria denmark and the
swedes
that they will not have to sort of shell
out for the
southern countries which will then sort
of waste their
money that is the main issue that is at
stake here that is what they're afraid
of what they fear that they cannot sell
politically at home
and on the other side the south where
the politicians are really clamoring
if you look at spain and particularly
italy
for help and quick help from brussels
from the european union
to overcome the deep slump the economy
is
falling into because of the coronal
crisis
and she will somehow have to give
something to everybody that is always
the very difficult task of the eu
presidency
she will have to make little parcels and
and offer
something to the netherlands somehow
mitigate mitigate
the problem they have with having to
give money
to this house and on the other hand she
will have to sort of tell the south
you just have to reign in your
expectations you have to be content
with what we can give you and make the
best of it
and then she has eastern europe also who
want a share
and a piece of the cake so it is very
very difficult and it sort of compromise
making of on the very very highest level
but barbara should we really be
optimistic given the recent
past record of a lack of consensus
building particularly in relation to for
example the migration
uh policy in the eu consensus has been
hard to come by
is germany confident that it will in
fact be able to build
consensus and one united voice on the
coronavirus recovery plan
relatively confident because they simply
have to find a compromise i mean this is
absolutely this absolutely needs to
happen and
everybody in the end even the dutch and
the austrians and the other
northern countries who are sort of
reluctant to sort of
dip into their pockets and put money on
the table and also they know that
it's they're all also their political
survival it's their economic survival
that's at stake and that is something
that angela merkel has
started saying again and again and i
suppose it's going to be one of the main
slogans one of the main sentences of her
eu presidencies
at presidency it is in your own interest
so she will have to go to margaret to
the dutch prime minister and say it is
in your own interest
if you help saving the european sounds
because if the eu falls apart
the dutch will be will be falling apart
too their economic
the economy will fail and and so she
will have to sort of sell this idea to
everybody
and she will just have to make very
clever and very smart little compromise
bits and pieces of compromise that the
people can take home and say
yes we got away relatively well out of
this big struggle
uh for the money in in brussels and
she will in the end be able to do it
because
it is not really on the horizon that one
of the 27 member states
will in the end say and no we'll say no
to this we walk away
it's it has never happened before but
it is going to be super super difficult
of course the other side of the
consensus coin
is a compromise as you were alluding to
barbara
nina uh angela merkel herself
crossed a red line didn't she when she
along with
emmanuel macron agreed to the concept of
joint debt
in the 500 billion euro package that
france and germany
are presenting how has that gone down
domestically
here in germany
you're right that is absolutely the case
she was long known as madame no
in france because of course the french
put a similar proposal on the table
years ago asking for the eu to issue
joint bonds so that money can be
generated that can be given to member
states and angela merkel always refused
that
debt pooling she said it needed to stay
in the fiscal discipline um field and
she was very rigorous when it came to
that topic
then she is somebody who is known to act
when disaster is looming
and she clearly understands that this is
an existential crisis and if
revolutionary and drastic measures
aren't taken this could go to the core
the very core of the european union she
does understand that which is why in
mid-may
she and the french president came
forward and put
this agreement on the table where they
said 500 billion euros
should be issued by the european
commission as
joint bonds on the market and that that
money could then be given as grants
to the countries that are hardest hit
like italy and spain as barbara just
described
and and not as loans and this is the big
controversy but this is also what some
people are calling remarkable
but i hinted at it in my first answer
that of course the german
members of parliament the german leaders
of the industry here they all
understand that if the european
economies around germany
fail if this is a crisis where the
countries don't get out of recession
then this is something that will affect
germany directly
seeing that germany is an export nation
so this is very much in germany's
self-interest but for a long time
she was madame no and she has clearly
changed her mind and people say it's
revolutionary and now with germany
taking over the
rotating presidency of the european
union clearly there's
expectations all across europe in
keeping with that
we asked some of our other
correspondents elsewhere in europe and
around the world about expectations for
germany's
eu presidency here's what people had to
say
since angela merkel took power in 2005
the uk has seen
five different prime ministers and that
is what the brits appreciate about the
german chancellor her endurance her
political skill
and her pragmatism her leadership was
greatly admired during the pandemic when
journalists repeatedly asked downing
street why great britain
wouldn't just follow germany's example
mackel is also seen as pulling the
strings in the eu
now the uk government is hoping that
mackel brings her pragmatism
to the brexit negotiating table to
secure a deal with the brits
germany is considered a reliable
development partner and when germany
took over the g20 presidency
mackel laid a strong focus on africa one
thing kenya will probably take a good
look at
is germany's role at the u.n security
council because at the end of the year
germany will be handing over the baton
to kenya as one of the non-permanent
members of the council
the rule of law is a sensitive issue
between warsaw and brussels
many polish people worry that they no
longer live in a constitutional state
they want europe to keep a closer eye on
the polish government
during the german presidency germany had
planned for a big
eu china summit in september where both
sides were to announce an investment
agreement
the summit has been cancelled due to
covet 19
and the negotiations on this agreement
are stuck moreover
western partners are very worried about
china's decision to
impose a national security law on hong
kong
germany has joined declarations voicing
concern
but has also been careful not to be
too vocal about its criticisms and
china's government will
certainly hope that germany will
continue to tone down its criticism for
the sake of economic relations
i left the united states just after the
inauguration of president donald trump a
little bit more than three years ago
and just came back to cover these
elections and to understand what is
going on in this country
many things have changed dramatically
but one thing remains the same
it's the respect for the german
chancellor and the popularity of angela
merkel
but as to the eu council presidency and
the presidency
in the un security council only very few
americans
know the difference they're far too
occupied with their own
problems here in their country if
anything
they want germany to pay more to nato
but that's the only thing which matters
here in washington the united states of
america
germany should pay more into nato the
constant refrain from the united states
uh parliamentary correspondent uh a
political correspondent i'm sorry nina
haser and
our brussels correspondent barbara
weasel are with me on the line barbara
i'd like to come to you first let's just
pick up on what
ens was reporting germany should be
paying more
into nato that seems to be the one line
that seems to define the relations
between the eu and the united states
are we looking at a change during
germany's presidency yeah the horrible
thing here really is that all this is a
huge
misunderstanding i mean nato is not a
club where you have sort of like a
common kitty and everybody has to sort
of throw some money and
nato is in the lines and defense
alliance where everybody has to take
care of their own
defense capabilities and then in the end
they pool their capita
capabilities so that's a completely
different picture but it is president
donald trump who has sort of come up
with this
and he uses as a propaganda tool against
germany
that is one of the few constants really
in his policies and so it is really
difficult or more or less impossible
to sort of go against that and to figure
out uh that
that germany will have to spend more and
does it increasingly
for its own expensive expenses for
defense
but it will not sort of put money into
nato
that concept simply doesn't exist uh
nina has i'd like to come to you
just going back to what uh correspondent
matthias bilinga
was reporting on from china that appears
to be
something that is an important
relationship for the eu
and germany as well how much flexibility
does chancellor angela merkel have
in relation to the relationship with
china
given that china is the eu's second
largest trading partner and a very
important
source of export for german businesses
flexibility
is of course um limited in that sense
that
everybody is aware that we can't
suddenly stop
trading with china that is a line that
we hear repeatedly here
nevertheless there's also a strong sense
that the
relationship with china needs to be
strategically
reformed on the european level and that
germany
should use the next six months to also
get european countries
around the table and make it clear that
europe does speak with one voice when it
comes to china
and that was actually the intention of
that eu-china summit that angela merkel
wanted to hold
in the german city of leipzig in
september then she postponed this summit
um
citing corona reasons some people are
saying this has to happen as quickly as
possible
because uh dialogue needs to be kept
open
but the opposition parties are severely
criticizing that fact that germany
wants to hold this eu-china summit they
say it's a propaganda spectacle so there
is a very very strong
debate that's going on here between
members of bundestag
nina hazar in berlin and barbara weasel
reporting
from brussels thank you both very much
for joining us